what's up everyone thanks for checking
out this week in cloud where we serve
you the lowest latency news now there's
a lot of great content at necks and I
mean a lot so much that well sorting
through all the sessions to find the
best ones for you can be stressful
that's why every day this week we're
publishing different playlists of
can't-miss sessions based on subject
area today's list data management app
dev and cloud infrastructure check back
later this week for data analytics
security and machine learning
this week on the GCP blog learn how to
get the most out of next start billing
your playlist today because we're headed
to Google next nineteen in just under a
month and speaking of next if you
haven't earned your cloud certifications
yet this could be the perfect
opportunity
why get certified perhaps the fact that
our certification for professional cloud
architect was just named the top paying
IT certification or maybe you just want
to show the world what you can do any
way you take it across the industry
demand for these roles is exploding and
so has our list of available
certifications we'll be offering these
exams at tons of convenient times
throughout next so go sign up one of the
big topics at next is machine learning
no matter what level of machine learning
you're looking to get involved with
Google has what you need if you want to
try training a model without any code
you can use Auto ml but if you need a
more complex model and want to go deeper
you probably want to use tensorflow
which is easier to experiment with now
more than ever thanks to our deep
learning VM instances these instances
are spun up with tensorflow and other
tools pre-installed to get you up and
running right away you can even include
GPUs while setting them up so see what
you can build now if you've ever been
extra concerned about who might be
reading your email have you heard about
Gmail confidential mode confidential
mode automatically removes the option of
forward copy download or print messages
it also lets you set requirements so
recipients must complete a text message
verification prior to opening and
viewing an email that you send them so
that way you can be sure only your
intended audience can see what you've
sent try out the beta by clicking
confidential mode in Gmail's user
settings if you want to read more about
these announcements or see a full list
check out the link have thoughts or
ideas leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you